Welcome, this is introduction to Robot Vision.
In this course we're going to talk about how
we give robots the sense of sight. Clearly
vision is a really important sense for us
in almost everything we do in our daily life.
And it plays a critically important role in
the life of almost all life forms on the planet.
So what I hope to do during this course is
convince you that vision is a really important
sense for robotics and we're going to talk
about how you actually get robots to understand
visual information. So this gets us into a
field that's called "Computer Vision" so we
can consider this course as the first few
steps into this big field of computer vision.
Computer vision is all about how you can use
cameras connected to computers to understand
the state of the world. It's a big field,
growing very, very quickly and it's massive
progress. But in this course, the first simple
steps into computer vision. So what we will
learn through the course is how we can take
images from a camera and use them to understand,
to find, to recognize objects of different
size or shape or colour. So very simple information,
but this is enough information that can be
given to a robot to enable it to carry out
some simple tasks. So we're going to take
an image with millions of pixels of information
in it and turn that into information that
a robot can act on.
I've spent almost my entire career working
on equipping robots with vision, the field
of robotic vision, so I hope in this course,
that I can convince you that vision is a really
important way for robots to sense the world
around them and that you will enjoy learning
some fundamentals of how it is we go about
making robots see.